oran que de sourires et nous quittons
l'enfance avant que de savoir la
jeunesse enfuie cela semble si court que
l'on le tout surpris car doit de
comprendre en kit l'existence lorsqu'on
tient entre ses mains
cette richesse d'avoir 20 ans les
lendemains plein de promesses quand
l'amour sur nous se penche pour nous
offrir ses nuits blanches
lorsque l'on voit loin devant soir
rires la vie
rodez d'espoir régime joie et de fruits
il faut boire jusqu'à l'ivresse
car tous les instants de long 20 ans
nous sont contées et jamais plus le
temps perdu nous fasse souvent à 20 dans
les mains mais on regrette qu'il est
trop tard car sur son chemin rien eu
on le peut sans cesse garder ça jamais